everybody
that's mine yeah
uh I've I put together a little packet
which I would like to go through very
very quickly here seeing that we're
doing dealing with the issue of Co-op
school districts and everything
associated with assets a portion that of
board members all that
I think it's important that we take a
little walk through so everybody's on
has a pretty good understanding of what
we're addressing here this is not an
issue unique to this particular year
I've been in the education on the
education committee for the last 14
years and I can't remember a year in
which we didn't discuss co-ops
um it's one of those topics that just uh
is very difficult because it had it it
it it entails talking about every aspect
of the state in terms of our demographic
our population and our organizational
structure so if you're if you have a
copy of this I'd like to Wade through it
first for
folks um
the way this thing came out I'll just
take the order of the sheets that are
there
um a co-op district is one which has
various school districts within it that
are are part of that Cooperative
agreement and it's an agreement which uh
you write amongst those people that are
coming to get districts coming together
and it's like a marriage
and if anybody's been through a divorce
fortunately I've never had that uh not
opportunity that decision to make but uh
it's it's it's difficult and it carries
with it so many issues and so many
strings
so the the first one shows you that
um uh in terms of the Randolph Gorham
Shelburne uh Co-op District issue and
then of course Merrimack Valley
Timberlane and conocook it showed us the
census when it was done uh did the
population acid that 2020 and the
percentage of the population that comes
from each particular community and the
seats whether they be a seat at large or
a seat That's Unique just uniquely to
that particular District
there are a number of Co-op districts if
you go to the sheet two there
apportionment formulas for Cooperative
disc school districts for your
information we have
over that's 30 plus Co-op districts in
the state and if you look at the number
of towns or school districts that that
involves it involves close to 120
districts within this state that's a
high number of the districts and so what
we're talking about we're talking about
issues here in these three bills which
impact from north to south and east to
west in the state of New Hampshire
so you go through and see all those
particular districts I for one live in a
district which is a co-op District
and within that district there are seven
at large members of which they all come
from the same community
it's because we had one Village District
that initially had their own school
since closed down and Woodsville is not
part of Haverhill so it's a Haverhill
co-op with just seven at-large members
they're all at large because one area
Town never
put anybody on the dock and to be voted
for so they all were coming initially
from North Haverhill and Woodsville
Haverhill Corner didn't care
so
looking at the the way they get together
there's articles of agreement and you
can see on the down in the next uh Below
in the packet there shows all the co-ops
there's an article of agreement we just
took that one District of the first pile
last year and years before we've looked
at this issue even when we had
representative Grenier in charge of a
committee a commission to look at this
we gathered many many articles of
agreement together this was just the
first one on top of the Heap I took it
and ran it off today so you can see that
there are articles which tells you how
members are apportions with to those
districts and how often the Agreements
are looked at to review or update be it
10 years or five years and there's a lot
to it usually you'll see seven uh 9 11
13 15 up to 15 members that can be on a
co-op board
uh going through this further here
um
and we've had some samples there of how
seats might be proportioned if you'd use
the one man one vote type
um uh
principle and lastly there is a sheet
there which shows we struggled with
apportionment last year and we did come
up with a Amendment which did not fly
the the bill was at the I think was the
Litchfield Bill and and that bill it we
it's not one we're discussing today
that's one that did have a lot more
energy given to it by the whole folks
here because you know we were looking at
one person one vote and in the smaller
districts sometimes are the ones which
don't have that they have to combine
with another one so with that
that's information available to you I'd
like to now just uh open this up to
where we have to be today the purpose of
the interim study is to recommend that
we either move forward with the these
bills
with legislation in the upcoming session
not necessarily these bills per se but
language which addresses some of the
what you see in the analysis of those
bills
go forward whether it make
recommendations go forward perhaps with
recommendations or if we make the
decision we're not going to move the
bill forward we're not going to move
that concept forward we're going to
leave it alone
so those are the only two options which
we really have and on the interim study
we're not here to design new legislation
we can
we can you know that's done individually
or by the group later on when we put in
and and put legislation in we've already
gone through one filing period which
opened up on September 6 and closed on
September 16th for those that are in the
house right now there will be another
filing period after the election and
that uh it will be when you'll see
anything if anything does come forward
uh regarding this so with that I'd like
to open this up and is there any further
discussion right now on these bills we
have
13.99 and 1679
1366 is relative to school board
reapportionment
1399 is relative School District
withdrawal from a school district
there's a lot of energy being put on
that and 1679 was came from my friend to
my right ear left representative
cordelli and we've gone through this for
a number of years and his concept was
let's just dissolve it all and start all
over again
that was so that's a relative to the
dissolution and repeal The Cooperative
school districts
uh we've gone through consolidation
schools over in the state of Maine and
as I recall when I was an administrator
over there we ended up consolidating one
school district Rumford Mexico and they
were going to do that anyways seeing
they're right on the Androscoggin river
there and there really are one Community
Vermont's also gone through an act over
there of which for my talking with as
superintendent was over there who's now
came back and left that state back in
New Hampshire here has now since retired
he indicated to me that the
administrative costs for their act are
higher now than they were before uh it's
it's so consolidation has some Financial
issues associated with it so
with that uh we're open the committee's
open now to discussion on any of the
three bills or or on the issue of
Cooperative schools representative
Mullen thank you Mr chair
um would you could you remind me whether
or not these bills came from
requests by Cooperative school districts
to change the membership or change the
the uh affiliation
the first two bills that we had in order
of numbering uh basically a result of uh
a district feeling that they didn't have
the the representative of that that
District was voted upon at large and and
uh the and I'm just trying to recall
with my memory too that the the person
did not was not domiciled in that
particular community and elected by the
people in that particular District they
were elected at large so the districts
of the greater population were were you
know deciding members on the board on
the co-op board I I believe that I may
be wrong uh reps and cordelli is that
you're
I believe that's generally the case yeah
and they were presented by by one
representative representative uh Power
was uh the one that right and just as a
follow-up comment I was asking because I
know the representative power is uh from
Merrimack which district is she from
Merrimack is it Merrimack
oh Hollis Brooklyn All right so she is
from a Cooperative District okay yeah
thank you yeah
further discussion on this okay I'll
open this up to the public too
um if uh if there is a an individual
here or a group that would like to speak
in regard to a concern dealing with a
Cooperative school districts or to offer
us some input and
how to make a decision here we'd welcome
that at this time
okay our New Hampshire school boards
Association welcome Barrett
good morning do you have your mic on
there you go good morning thank you
chairman Ladd good morning members of
the committee bear Christina from the
New Hampshire school boards Association
I bet you're all surprised to see me
here when we're talking about these
bills
um just to um once again reiterate as I
mentioned
um a handful of times last year nhsba's
position would be that the legislature
adopt a two-year-long study commission
so we can do this properly we can bring
in the dra we can bring in the Secretary
of State's office or AG to talk about
the one-man one vote we can bring in
school board members from Cooperative
School District superintendents from
Cooperative school districts into a very
comprehensive review of RSA 195 in its
totality these sort of Patchwork
approaches
um in my opinion an nhsbe's opinion do
not fit for the complexities of the 32
co-ops in in this state
um so that would be nhsba's
recommendation
hmm thank you would you give maybe the
committee a brief overview for example
if I'm a district and I want out
the about the feasibility study the
sustainability of it and then how the
State Board interacts with the local
board sure I can talk about that a
little bit um I I do know that there we
do have an attorney in the audience who
has worked with school districts related
going through withdrawal processing so
he probably has better specific
information and knowledge than I would
um but essentially a warrant article can
be placed on a school district warrant
to study withdrawal or or to study the
makeup of your portion formula or to
review your articles of agreement you
can do that at any time there is another
odd twist in the co-op statute where
um on the town warrant at the Town
annual meeting that one of the towns
that is part of the co-op can
um have on the town warrant a a a
petition warrant article to study
withdrawal if that passes then the
school board of the co-op district is
obligated to initiate a withdrawal study
the statutes relative to dissolution of
of property are are confusing and I
don't have the best handle on those to
be quite honest with you I was in our
office uh yesterday with our staff
attorney trying to assist one community
that is in the middle of a withdrawal
process and we read the statute six
different ways and came up with a
different conclusion six different times
so
um but essentially there's a study a
study committee
um uh made up of a couple people from
each of the towns I believe the
superintendent is an ex-officio member
of that committee
um and I think you can add people to the
committee sometimes I've seen select
board members or various constituents
from either of the communities and they
run through the numbers they talk about
how much it would cost they talk about
if there are if there's any outstanding
indebtedness if there's a for example a
bond on on a building and what person
may have to or what community may have
to sort of pay pay back a portion of
that Bond there's discussions about this
of about
um uh not just real property but
personal property desks and computers
and what's going to happen with the
teachers and things of that nature so
the committee then uh it comes up with a
withdrawal plan either excuse me they
make a recommendation to either yes
person withdrawal or not pursue
withdrawal at that point
um the the the the the plan if you will
or the findings go to the State Board
there is a provision law that allows for
Minority Report to go to the State Board
we added that in the law about five
years ago
um so it's a lot more complex than that
but I mean I I also don't want to sit
here for an hour explaining every Nuance
of of RSA 195 and with withdrawal
statutes so if the State Board accepts
the withdrawal plan or denies that that
what's the next step back it goes back
to the vote it goes back to the voters
um one of the uh interesting things is I
have to double check I believe the vote
to withdraw is Co-op wide though it's
not just the community it's not just the
one town within the co-op that's looking
to to uh to withdraw and I guess the
rationale for that was when the co-op
was formed it took a vote of all the
communities to form the co-op so I guess
um you know it takes takes two parties
to get married and in this case I guess
it takes two parties to get divorced too
and you can't just run off and the town
can't just file for divorce on on its
own
um I know that that was been an issue in
some communities as well too but
essentially the State Board would either
approve or disapprove the proposal and
then it goes back to the voters of the
co-op Co-op wide and they ultimately
vote on whether or not that town can or
should withdraw thank you that's just my
understanding too yes representative
Luna
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much Mr Christina in um in 195
um uh which has uh well 195 has a number
of sections in it 18 I think talked
specifically about
um uh Cooperative school districts and
IT addresses the um the art the what
what has to be in the um the art the
articles of agreement and uh and
one of the things it talks about is
dissolution but does it also I guess is
is withdrawal the same or or different
is it the same or different than
dissolution and have you do do
um
does the does the statute provide any
I guess standards for for for what needs
to be considered in um in an article of
withdrawal or an article
um for dissolution thank you for the
question
um representative
um I believe withdrawal and dissolution
are are different things dissolution
means that the co-op is no longer
existing as a corporate legal entity for
example a number of years ago the Goshen
lemster School Cooperative School
District dissolved so you had two single
districts then you had Goshen and
lemster there's no more Cooperative
that's a dissolution alternatively if
you had a three-town co-op in one town
with Drew the two remaining towns would
not have dissolved it would have been
amended if you will
um so so yes there's a difference
between a withdrawal and a dissolution
dissolution the the co-op no longer
exists as a legal entity withdrawal you
might have one Community withdraw from a
four or five Town Co-op the remaining
town still exists as as the co-op and I
for forget what the second part of your
question was representative something
about right right so so um
yeah and I'll actually turn it into a
follow-up go ahead Rick
um
so so in in in the in the
in the Statue 195 18 uh where the state
does require agreements to to have um
yep to have uh uh a provision for this
dissolution
um does the state also require provision
in the Articles of agreement for
withdrawal and then the um the really
the the question is does the state does
the statute get into any details in
terms of in terms of what is permitted
um in the Articles of agreement right in
in any of these
um different areas or is it really left
up to the uh the the co-op in the city
sure one of one of the problems
um with the statute as currently written
is that it oftentimes
um uses different words but there seems
to be an implication that they're
intended to mean the same thing so under
195 RSA 195 18 procedure for formation
of a Cooperative school district and
this is down in subparagraph k
for Cooperative school districts formed
after the date of this subparagraph
which I believe is probably 1963 a plan
for dissolution of the co-op so you're
you're you're you're you're you're
you're you're forming documents your
your articles of agreement have to have
a plan for dissolution but there's
nothing in there that talks about a plan
upon withdrawal of one of the members in
terms of what has to go into the
withdrawal plan that is RSA 195 colon
26. what's interesting about that I was
just talking about this with our with
our statute or our staff attorney
yesterday
um there's a conflict between 195 26 and
195.28
um
uh uh I'm trying to find where that
where that was
um
so for example uh
so I'm in 195 28 if you have in front of
you
the last the second to last sentence the
amount of said Capital Improvements and
additions at the time of the transfer
title shall be determined by the
agreement for withdr for withdrawal
between the Cooperative school district
and the withdrawn School District so
agreement for withdrawal there's no
agreement for withdrawal that's
generally that's described as a
withdrawal plan in the earlier statutes
but the other interesting aspect about
that where it says the amount of said
Capital Improvements and additions and
the time of transfer title if you go
back up to 195.26
I don't think it talks about
it doesn't necessarily talk about the
Capital
Improvements and additions there's some
language in there about outstanding
indebtedness so there's some conflict
between 195 28 and 195 26 about what
needs to be within the plan I will say
that the withdrawal plans are using much
more comprehensive than what than what
195 26 requires that's my sort of
anecdotal knowledge if you will
so do do all do all um articles of
agreement
have to include a withdrawal plan not a
withdrawal plan but
um if we go back up to 195.18
the articles of agreement are supposed
to include
so we see you know we've paragraph three
of 195.28 says the Cooperative School
District planning board May recommend
that a Cooperative School District
composed of all the districts
represented by his membership so on and
so forth the planning board self-repair
proposed articles of agreement for the
proposed Cooperative School District
which shall be signed by a majority of
the planning board which shall set forth
the following and then it will sell
paragraph a through l or k or whatever
it is and then K talks about the
dissolution so the articles of agreement
have to have a provision about what
happens upon dissolution of the co-op
but the articles of agreement the
forming the formational documents don't
have to have anything in there about
withdrawal of the agreement
thank you
well thank you Mr chair obviously when
uh co-ops have formed there was some
sense of consensus on need and common
interest
Etc
and over the years
those interests may change
politics may change numbers may change
so when a um
dissolution or a withdrawal takes place
I want to focus on the withdrawal issue
and you have
a new school district basically created
as a result of the withdrawal
my question deals with the fiscal nature
of this
that obviously when you have a co-op
there's a there's a sharing of costs
from the various School various
communities Etc
but when that withdrawal takes place
that community that withdraws Bears the
burden of the fiscal nature of running a
school district
so my question has to deal with the
increased cost
that may come to a community or a lot or
a decrease in cost perhaps what's been
your experience as it relates to the
impact on the citizens and the students
in that withdrawal as it relates to the
fiscal cost of the withdrawal sure thank
you very much for the for the question
representative um I'll be quite honest
with you I don't know if I have any
direct knowledge as to what sort of the
resulting fiscal or educational impact
has been in the town that that is
withdrawn I'm trying to think of I mean
there haven't been too many towns that
have withdrawn from co-ops in the last
15 years maybe a couple Statewide
messinic kind of blew up a number of
years ago
um you know there have been there have
been efforts I know there were some
issues in Timberlane there's an issue
with Carol going on right now
um you know my experience again
anecdotally and just remember some of
the people that we brought in with the
study commission five or six years ago
whenever that was chairman Ladd
um a lot of the complaints seem to do
with um sort of the apportionment
Formula One Town feeling that they were
paying too much
um you know or one town feeling that
they were paying too much and not
necessarily getting the services back
for their kids and perhaps their little
Elementary School
um you know and and so I don't have any
direct experiences to the the fiscal
impact
um I will say though it probably you
know if if a community withdraws from a
from a co-op and they simply turn around
and tuition their kids back to the same
high school that they were going
um
you know I don't I I don't know if that
flat tuition cost
is is the true cost of what's causing to
educate those kids in that building so
it seems like the remaining towns in the
co-op May then be footing some of the
bill Capital costs things of that nature
for those kids that are coming back in
that were already there to begin with
uh follow up please follow up one of the
issues that
has come before us
it's been Hollis Brookline
Hollis Brookline has come before this
committee several times as far as in
conversations
and the Dynamics that have changed
between both Hollis and Brookline with
where the high school is located
vis-a-vis where there's been a growth in
the other community right how does uh
how does the co-op deal with that when
you've got when you have that kind of uh
yeah I mean that kind of conflict that
begins with this so thank you very much
for the question representative what
often
I think is not mentioned in this
committee and maybe I should do a better
job of bringing it up is there are
Provisions in law that allow you to
amend your articles of agreement without
withdrawing you can you can remember
your articles of agreement at any time
it takes planning and it takes some work
and you have to have a a study committee
and look at the numbers and bring in the
dra numbers and your business you know
your business manager to run the
apportion formulas
um you know and there's also you know
you can the law allows communities
co-ops to change the apportionment
formula from either you know property
value or students or some combination
thereof you know number of heads versus
what the the property values are in the
community and you can do anything from
zero percent to one hundred percent on
any of those so
um you know you can we talked about this
last session there are Provisions to
change the way that the Cooperative
school board members are elected those
are already allowed in law
how many districts are going through
sort of changes or planning changes to
to amend the current and you know keep
the status quo with the communities but
yet change what I I have no idea I don't
I don't know
um I will tell you that you know nhsba
let's say the last three or four years
maybe even a little bit longer because I
don't know how much of this was going on
during the during the pandemic
um you know we we work with some
Consultants um where a a board will call
us and say we think we want to withdraw
or we think we want to study withdrawal
but we're not sure we're there yet can
you send somebody down and help us do
some pre-work if you will before we get
down the road of doing the statutory
study commission and whatnot and so you
know I've got some consultants usually
former business managers or former
superintendents that have been in co-ops
that understand sort of the nature of of
what a co-op is
and they'll go down and they'll do six
months worth of work and they say you
know what it may not be perfect but it's
better than the alternative we see that
quite a bit as well too
represent cordelli thank you Mr chairman
um getting back to the point about uh
dissolution plans in the Articles of
agreement
um I think that that
subparagraph came into effect only as a
result of the uh 1997 study
um that you referred to earlier and that
actually no Co-op has been formed since
that point so in effect no articles of
agreement are required to have
um an article related to dissolution
would you say that is correct yeah thank
you very much representative Cordell if
that provision paragraph K I believe it
is is a you know relatively newer
provision within the last what 15 20
years or so that would that would make
sense then that that the and since we
haven't I think there's been one Co-op
that's been formed in the last
15 20 years but it was sort of an
expansion Wilton wine Borough they were
a co-op for I believe the middle school
and high school and there was a Wilton
Elementary School in a lineborough
elementary school I want to say maybe 10
12 years ago they just made the whole
thing K-12 so it really wasn't A
disruption or a new town coming into
anything same SAU same teacher same
staff same superintendent but yeah if
that's a newer provision that would make
sense because we haven't had any like
brand new co-ops informed in decades
right follow-up thank you
um I I think in the discussion of
withdrawals
um that has been the most common
um legislation that we've seen over the
past well 10 years that I've been here
in terms of bills that have been filed
that's
um certainly they all or the majority of
them deal with the withdrawal process
and
um 13.99 is example of that right I
think one of the problems
um I think you said there was only a
couple of withdrawals that have occurred
a single
school from the from the cooperative and
I think one of the reasons for that is
that
um in most cases
um the larger District within the co-op
if it's a district-wide co-op
district-wide vote a small town that
might want to withdraw has virtually no
chance to get passage of uh their
withdrawal
so I think that that's an inherent
problem that we have with the current
laws sure
good
not really a question but I would
welcome your comments sure thank you
very much representative
um I I yeah we've certainly heard that
that the the large community carries
carries the vote
um I will say um just trying to think of
a couple of the communities that I know
have withdrawn
just at least in my tenure at nhsba
which gets longer and longer every year
um uh Surrey and Sullivan both withdrew
from I believe that was the Monadnock
Regional that was maybe 15 years ago
very small communities
um Mason withdrew from
um uh messenic maybe
2007 8 9-ish
um and I don't know how and that's
Greenville and New Ipswich and I forget
if there's another community in Miss
Scenic and I don't know the how how big
Mason is compared to all those others so
um I I understand that we hear that and
I understand that that may be a concern
in some communities but there are other
examples of very small communities being
able to withdraw from from a co-op
uh Barrett do you have any uh districts
contacting you and saying Okay
um we would want to look at our articles
of agreement there's yeah all these 32
different co-ops of which all those
articles are different yeah and that's
part of our quandary too how do we deal
with this we we
um we don't we have not been asked to
review them for the sake of a review we
from time to time and not very common
I've been asked to look at them just to
see if if if if the articles of
agreement support something that they're
trying to do whether some sort of
Warrant article or some sort of change
in something like that
um but I mean just asking us to do a
review of their articles of agreement to
see if what could be changed I haven't
been asked to do that I've made the
private attorneys may have but we
haven't so my question is last year we
had some language which was in one of
our amendments and it read
reapportionment of members of The
Cooperative School Board shall be
reviewed revised and updated no less
frequently than every 10 years and
reapportions if necessary based upon the
latest Federal DC Centennial census
right so every 10 years is this
currently
occurring our our co-ops looking at
their articles of agreement and trying
to amend them to stay current with law
yeah I mean I I think I think
I think they're certainly reviewing them
just because this is be you know we're
hearing more and more
um of this as representative cordelli
said we get a lot of bills the last 10
years or so so I think people are
reviewing them
um but when I say reviewing them I don't
know if that's happening in any sort of
formal sense through a committee or
process or anything I think the board
members are looking at them the
superintendents are looking at them so
on and so forth in terms of the the the
the the the every 10 years or whatnot I
mean again yeah that might be a best
practice
um if that were to make it into law you
know it would at least put people it
would at least get people being aware of
their articles of agreement and how
things might need to change
um but again sort of the larger question
about legislation is you know is again
to reiterate I would prefer to see a big
study commission where all these
questions can be answered and we can
have experts come in and and hopefully
get some sort of clarification with the
Statue and the last question on this
topic now let down
um in in your knowledge what's going on
in the state from the school board
perspective
um
are are this
are there a majority or very few that
are really having problems with their
Cooperative organization uh the school
district are are we dealing with an
issue that is Statewide or are we
dealing with a few districts yeah thank
you very much
um
I'd say somewhere in between
um you know 10 years ago I think it was
a district here district there today
there's certainly more District towns
looking at least looking at studying
withdrawal not necessarily me saying
they want to withdraw but I think maybe
that gets back to your point is maybe we
should be reviewing these articles of
agreement every 10 years
um you know have something set so you
know doing the review process
in for perhaps somewhat informally
before we get into a formal withdrawal
process because sometimes the train
starts going and it's hard to hard to
stop that train
um so you know I I don't think it's
necessarily A A Statewide issue I think
we've certainly heard concerns from a
community here or Community there but
then again I guess that brings me back
to the point that the current law
already allows us to make amendments to
all these sorts of things too the way
your your board members are elected the
articles of agreement the apportionment
formulas whether or not you're using
property values or or per student counts
there's a lot of flexibility in there
and you know so
I think it's not as much as it was 10 I
think it's more than it was 10 years ago
I don't know if it's still a lot that
it's a Statewide issue are there any
other questions yes representative
Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um I came into the state as a teacher
right when all this was happening in in
the late 60s and I was wondering if you
could speak to how at that point the the
Department of Education and also the
state as a whole was encouraging these
co-ops and why and as compared to today
how the state and the New Hampshire
Department of Education is supporting
the co-ops sure thank you very much for
the question representative I mean I you
know
it may come to a surprise but I was not
alive in 1963 when these were when these
were uh uh being formulated
um
I had a lot less gray hair before I
started coming down here every day
though I'll tell you that
um uh I bet I bet the two of you did as
well too
um but um so again my understanding just
doing some research of this throughout
the course of the year so that the the
co-op statute as we know it now was
primarily written in 1963.
um you know the you know and I got New
Hampshire is probably a much
significantly different place today than
it was in 1963.
um but it was it the purpose of it was
basically to create Regional High
Schools Cooperative high schools and
perhaps some middle schools where each
town would kind of retain its little
elementary school but it didn't make
sense you know from a fiscal standpoint
for every community of a thousand people
to have their own Middle School and High
School building so you know so they
reached analyzed to save costs
administrative costs building costs so
on and so forth you know if you had the
high school in your town fantastic if
you had to drive 30 40 minutes over the
mountains well I'm too you know too bad
um but the the the the the if you look
at if you look at the co-op map the map
of all the co-ops and the towns that are
within those co-ops you're going to find
a mix of property rich and property poor
towns that was done on purpose that was
done on purpose to help share the costs
with a recognition that public education
was for the greater good so
um you know what the Department's doing
now in terms of co-ops I don't I don't
know specifically I don't you know if if
people are calling the department
attorneys relative to co-op issues I'm
not aware of that so I don't know
um they call us from time to time again
you know we try and it's interesting
when a school board calls us relative to
a potential Co-op withdrawal because we
have to walk a very fine line because
our client Our member is the Co-op as it
exists right now and I'm obligated to
not do anything or give any legal advice
that may be contrary to the interest of
that of that Collective Co-op body
school board so we always tell boards
look we can help you with process right
timelines and this is who's got to be on
the committee and what the statute says
but we can't give any advice as to yes
this is a good idea or no this is a bad
idea we can't do that that's not that's
for the people in that Community to do
to to determine so NHS the the scope or
extent of nhsba's assistance when
districts are studying withdrawal is
more process driven we can tell them
okay this is what the statute says this
is what has to be in your plan this is
the timeline you know this is our best
interpretation of what this statute
means but you really need to call local
Council or have you know a private
attorney assist you with interpreting
all these things because it's not it's
not our place to do that
thank you
I I know that uh the Department of
Education is present here with their
attorney and perhaps we can hold that
question off as far as is the doe
engaged in any Cooperative discussions
with various districts at this time
and I I believe they are
um
yes cordelli and thank you
um in terms of required review
um maybe your memory is better than mine
but I seem to recall that a required
review of the
um articles of agreement is only
required for co-ops that were formed
before 1963.
God sorry no I just wondering if you're
you have uh recollection
yeah thank you very much for the
question representative I'm just trying
to do a quick yeah research here I was
too I don't I don't recall offhand
possibly I don't recall offhand though
okay all right
um secondly if I could just
um with uh Amendment of the Articles of
agreement
um is that also a district
Co-op wide vote so again
um a smaller District who wants a change
to the articles in terms of enforcement
might have a difficult time yeah that
has to go on the warrant it's a warrant
article that would have to be voted on
Co-op wide among all the communities
you know there'd be a problem
yeah further questions of the school yes
representative Nelson
thank you I've been in several of these
situations when sau13 split from sau9
and also for governor wentworth's School
District
in our town a little American Governor
Wentworth we're a small town 750 people
no businesses
we pay probably the highest taxes and
there's some people on this committee
that pay the lowest but that's neither
here nor there I won't look at represent
cordelli
um good for them but for us to have
withdrawn we have no school right and so
we were up to Creek right there and we
when they uh Finance some of these
buildings yeah there was like a 30 years
payment we had to pay out 25 years so it
was absolutely pretty much impossible
for us to grow up financially yeah yeah
that's I've I've heard of that in other
communities as well too where just that
if you don't have a facility in your
community but yet there's still a bond
out on the high school you have to and
you want to withdraw you have to pay
your fair share because you were part of
the co-op when they took that bond out
so you have to pay whatever your
proportional share would be to
so kind of like alimony I guess you know
so Barrett in conclusion here then from
uh from the school boards Association
perspective
um you've sort of advocated that this
might be addressed best through a
commission study another commission
study the last Grenier one that came up
with like 10 recommendations or ten
areas that he looked at was that a
committee or was that a commission that
was a commission it was a commission
okay and uh so
um
give me your ballpark your perspective
of what you think if if uh the latter
bill which we have which is
representative cardelli's bill here did
this dissolve the whole situation yeah
um and maybe go into the tuition program
um what would be the your your
understanding of costs that we may be
looking at here and that is always a
concern to me is the financial cost the
state might be in in you know walking
down the path into you know if if you
were to just dissolve all the co-ops
today I mean my first question would be
you the first thing you'd have to look
at from a cost standpoint anyway would
be how many of these co-ops have
outstanding bonds and who's going to pay
for that
right I mean is it still if we're just
dissolving Force dissolution then you
know I know that that's a lengthy bill I
don't I didn't read it since last
session so there may have been a
provision in there about you know the
you still have to do other communities
still have to pay their fair share of
the bonds or whatnot and the other thing
too is you know
there may be concerns in a community
here or Community there and there may be
the situation as representative Nelson
and representative Cordell we talk about
where the small town can't get out
either because they don't have the votes
or it's not fiscally prudent you know
that doesn't mean we need to blow up the
system seems to be like you'd be
throwing the baby out with the bath
water
um
you know if if if the intent of that
bill was just to sort of leave some of
the concerns that we've talked about the
last whatever since I've been up here
half hour 45 minutes or whatever it's
been
um you know I still come back that while
they may not be perfect there are
alternatives currently in law that allow
for changes that there may that may come
with some challenges as well too I won't
dispute that
um but you know
I think we need to you know all sort of
address those issues as well too if we
have a study commission so when we have
what do we have three five Co-op bills
every year we did the commission a
number of years ago and we get a couple
people here seems to be from generally
from some of the same communities and
the same people if we have a study
commission I mean the first thing that I
would do with that study commission is
we're not doing we're not talking about
legislation we're not talking about a
portion of formula we're going to do two
two or three hour listening sessions if
you're in a co-op community and you have
a concern or complaint or you think
something's great and you have a model
that works come and talk to the
commission because that that's what
we're going to want to hear that'll be
the first thing that I would do before
we even got into the dra and
apportionments and voting I'd hear I'd
want to hear from the people in the 32
co-ops about are you happy if not what's
the concern have you tried addressing it
locally have you gone through the the
amendment process already in law and
then hear from other co-ops where things
are going well and they've come up with
Creative Solutions to help believe
deviate the concerns of of that town or
that community
thank you
well we may have a little bit of an
opportunity to listen today to some that
may be coming from co-ops that are
having you know that love it or are
trying to get out of it uh thank you
very much thank you very much Mr chair
hey good morning Rick before we go on
would it be valuable for this group to
have a copy of that 97 the 1997 study
well yeah I think as much information
you can have I I don't have them myself
okay very great thank you Glenn thank
you welcome hi good morning my name is
Jim O'Shaughnessy I'm an attorney at
German Woodson it's a law firm in
Manchester as well as Maine and I
represent essentially exclusively school
districts and my firm represents a lot
of school districts in New Hampshire and
Maine and um
I think I was doing a rough estimate
right now
um we work with about 18 Cooperative
school districts in the state I'm
general counsel for around 10 12 of
those school districts I've been
involved in a number of study
commissions
um specifically working with the
districts who are in the process of
having having withdrawal study
conducted I've worked with also towns
who are has have hired me to advise them
on the potential for them to withdraw
from a Cooperative that was a couple of
years ago I think 2019 I worked with the
Charles uh Charlestown School the town
of Charlestown and their consideration
on withdrawing from Fall Mountain I've
testified a number of times that the
State Board I've been through a lot of
those meetings I've known a lot of
school boards a lot of community members
select board members so I have a fair I
think a really robust
experience just in terms of what folks
in the state are talking about I was on
the 2017 study commission where we
studied the um the withdrawal process in
195 25 and 26 that came up with you know
the grenier's committee that came up
with some recommended language that
actually revised the withdrawal process
and kind of streamlined it and made it a
lot more clear we did some good work and
I'll just start by saying that study
commission was a was a we talked a lot
there was not a lot of expertise there
were a lot of people with interest but
there was not a lot of expertise on the
commission so we had a hard time sort of
streamlining and coming up with really
good solutions to some of the problems
that just remained on the table and I
can talk about you know where I think
there are issues that are are impacting
both the communities looking to withdraw
and the Cooperative as a whole or the
communities that remain in a Cooperative
um
I just want to uh I just want to clarify
a couple things
um there are really two types of there's
many types of cooperatives in New
Hampshire but there are really two types
in terms of how they were formed there
are cooperatives that were formed prior
to 1963 and prior to the adoption of 195
18 and some of those cooperatives
predate the statute they were formed by
a special Act of the legislature in the
1950s and 60s the some of those
cooperatives don't in fact have articles
of agreement I represent a client that
does not actually have written articles
of agreement the articles of agreement
are essentially what the annual meeting
voters approve from time to time with
respect to the apportionment formula for
operating costs and capital costs so
there's the pre-1963 districts and
there's a post 1963 districts that are
subject to 195 18. how many excuse me
for putting in but how many are how many
pre no districts I knew at one point I
can't remember I there's not a there's
not a large number of 1963 districts but
there are some out there Monadnock is a
good example of a pre-1963 district and
I think if you go on the doe website
there are often dates of formation on
there and and I've counted I just don't
recall
um
so those all cooperatives the other
thing I want to explain is all
cooperatives are comprised of what we
call pre-existing districts because
there's a lot of confusion about what
happens when a school district enters
into a Cooperative with another school
district and unless that school district
continues to operate elementary schools
or other schools it it disappears it is
absorbed into the Cooperative so
um we often think about them as the town
school districts still remaining there
is no Town School District in fact by
law if the Cooperative absorbs that
pre-existing School District as a member
and that's important because when a
Cooperative is formed in the
pre-existing school districts are
absorbed in the Cooperative there it now
separate entity they're a separate
Municipal Corporation and the thinking
behind that is they are doing it because
they are putting their own individual
town taxes and needs and in interest
aside for the collaborative Cooperative
um you know Improvement of education for
all the kids in the co-op it's a sort of
holistic view of what is our
responsibility as a cooperative and that
is the spirit of why a lot of these
cooperatives were formed
um a bit of history on that in in 1961
the legislature formed a Cooperative
study commission that provided the
impetus for the adoption of 195 18.
the commissioner at the time was a big
supporter of the need to improve how we
were educating primarily our high school
students in particularly rural or poor
communities and so the Department of
Education was very supportive of let's
get out there and form these
cooperatives and combine these school
districts and regionalize education and
so the 1961 study which is available I
have a copy I think I copied it from the
State library because my mentor John
Tague was very was very involved in in
studying that and um that document
really is the sort of the the driving
force behind the commissioner of
Education going out and actually doing
the matchmaking and putting the
districts together
and you probably are aware at the time
that the legislature offered a lot of
building aid for school districts to
build their Cooperative schools that
probably was the biggest motivating
factor for cooperatives forming in the
60s
um
there's all there's a I'm happy to
answer questions there's a lot of
there's a lot of things I could go
through
um you ask the question
um is this a Statewide issue or is this
the sort of
individual issue I did a rough estimate
you know of the
of the districts I work with
less than a third of them have have
contemplated or have had a withdrawal
study Commission in the last you know
five ten years uh so I wonder if that's
a kind of a relevant number like a third
of the state has sort of gone through
the process of saying should we talk
about withdrawal should we revise our
apportionment formula about a third of
my districts have gone through that
process from time to time
um withdrawal and the apportionment
process those are um those are subject
to votes by the legislative body and and
it all turns out on on turns on who
shows up
at the ballot to vote
um or who shows up at the annual meeting
to vote it is inherently a democratic
process and
there are always winners and losers and
some folks are unhappy with losing and
it's it's a really tough thing because
the withdrawing town has to approve and
the Cooperative has to approve we
decided that once and for all when when
in that commission and we when the
legislature passed the revisions to
195.25
that's really the thing that is holding
a lot of it back is getting both bodies
to understand and to vote
um appropriately
this is an incredibly complicated
process there are so many facets and
every Cooperative has its own different
political Dynamic there's so many legal
issues there's dollars involved it's
incredibly hard advising from my
perspective advising superintendents and
school boards about what you're doing
what are the implications what are the
documentation what what's the work you
have to do to study this it's very very
challenging
imagine how much more challenging it is
than to roll that out to all the voters
so everyone understands here's what
we're going sitting down and voting on
today
um
that's the big challenge is it's
complicated so
um
I think Barrett answered the question
correctly the the way to do this is for
those study commissions to slow down
um to put in a the work
um and not try to rush it or wait to the
last minute because a lot of times it's
not a professional package when when
it's proposed at the end of the day and
that's often the complaint when it goes
before the state board or it goes before
the voters that this was sort of a
half-baked effort it was thrown together
at the last minute the numbers aren't
accurate there's not enough detail in
the withdrawal report the the dollars
more calculated correctly there's
assumptions that are often made that the
withdrawing districts kids will still
get to continue to go to The Cooperative
High School which is not a guarantee
under the law so there's so many
assumptions made in these half-baked
withdrawal reports that the voters
aren't confident in them and often
that's the reason why they fail in my
experience
um
uh I I have I wanted to talk a little
bit I know we haven't even we've talked
sort of generally I wanted to dig in a
little bit on
on the actual legislation 1679 the
dissolution bill I mean from a legal
perspective I think that's just a
non-starter no offense but I can't even
possibly fathom how that could happen I
I think it's interesting to throw this
idea out for sort of conceptual reasons
but um for me it it's it's uh it's
unfathomable because I don't know how
all those districts would then negotiate
all those tuition agreements with all
the all the high schools it would the
cost would be astronomical
um and I don't and ultimately and
fundamentally politically uh you have a
legislature making decisions for the the
local communities
um I feel like that's a local community
decision and it just really ought to
remain a local community decision
um
I think 1399 uh is an interesting bill
because it attempts for the first time
to fix some of the issues that exist in
the statute with respect to the the
disposition of property after a
withdrawal and this gets into the
nitty-gritty and this is where I'm
telling you everybody gets really
confused and all wrapped up in what does
the law mean and what does the law say
um but 195 28 is the statute that that
really relates to what happens to the
property in the districts that are
withdrawing from a co-op so if if I I
don't know what example we're using
right now that that makes sense and
that's sort of an easy one to think
about but you let's say you have a
multi-district Cooperative formed made
up of several pre-existing towns and it
covers K through 12.
preschool through 12.
there are all kinds of co-ops out there
but let's just take that simple model
K-12 multi-pre-existing School District
Cooperative in one town has an
elementary school and they withdraw
what happens with that elementary school
who pays whom for what
and how much
is really what 195 28 talks about and so
the current language in 195 28 that I
think
throws a wrench in the process is the
withdrawing District gets titled to
their property they get title to their
school it's the transfer of ownership
from Cooperative back to the town after
withdrawal you get it now you're you're
you become your own District you're
reformed as as a district you get your
school only after it pays
The Cooperative
for all of the capital expenditures
improvements that the Cooperative has
made
throughout the history of its existence
that's a pretty daunting I mean in 1960
whatever three or 1977 when they came up
with that the co-ops were 15 20 years
old so it was like all right you know
that makes sense well now we're looking
back at 60 we're only 60 years ago how
you know there was a there was a new
roof put on that building that's been
replaced twice but now we're expected to
to reimburse the co-op for the capital
outlay for the roof it doesn't make
sense so as a result we end up kind of
fudging the numbers or saying well we'll
look back 30 years or some other amount
of time but the fact is the dollar
amount at the end of the day
is huge
um and it's huge dollars regardless of
the condition of the school
um you know how much it you know what
its actual value might be it's not a
value based it's just the the actual
money spent so 13.99 proposes
a different method but it's not a good
method either it's closer to being a
good method but it's not a good method
um because it says that the withdrawing
District gets paid
for its proportional share of the net
equity and the remaining buildings and
then the Cooperative has to has to pay
them to get they get their bill the
kernel States the so it says hold on
um
takes its buildings with them and must
pay back to the other members of the
co-op each member's proportional share
in the net Equity so so the building is
appraised
and the withdrawing District only has to
pay back the the entire co-back Co-op
for its proportional share of the value
of the building
so it's like it only has to pay like
this this tiny amount so let's say that
that elementary school is worth a
million dollars
and there are five districts they only
have to pay
four hundred thousand dollars is that
the right math
right they only have to pay this tiny
amount yet they're getting the full
value of their building back is that the
Cooperative paid for
so that method isn't fair either because
it it really
um it's very one-sided it just favors
the the withdrawing districts interest
over that of the co-op in the remaining
towns they're basically getting the bad
end of the stick the withdrawing
district is getting its building back
for a song so what makes more sense to
me is to is that the withdrawing
district has to pay the co-op for the
actual value of the building you're
getting your building what's it worth
pay the co-op you get your building
um
that's almost what 1399 accomplishes but
it doesn't get there it could could get
there
um I have another concern with 1399
section 2 talks about the value of
property being appraised by a
three-person committee
it's a fine idea I'm sure we could sort
of nitpick that idea of an appraisal the
problem is I see it into is it doesn't
actually dictate what the appraisal
method is what's are we going to base it
on fair market value what's the fair
market value of a school building built
in 1920.
that has a new roof you know what I mean
like there is no really good Market or
Fair way to calculate fair market value
if you ask real estate appraisers to
appraise the fair market value of old
elementary school buildings they're all
over the place and I don't think that
serves anybody because it's you could
end up with an astronomically High
number or a really weird low number so
to me
the better method
um is like the cost
um
you take the replacement cost
so what would it cost to build a new
school
minus depreciation which is a method
they use and a lot of different a lot of
similar circumstances so that's a
different and maybe a better way of
calculating what the value is of that
old school building replacement cost
minus depreciation because it would cost
20 million dollars in today's dollars to
buy that school but it's we've had it
for 40 years so what's the current value
today that's a that's an appropriate
appraisal method
part two doesn't dictate an appraisal
method it needs to I don't think we
should delegate that to a three-person
committee without the legislature saying
what that method should be I'm not
saying I know for sure but I'm giving an
example of one potentially better method
that would be fair
to the withdrawing district and that
would be fair to the remaining members
of the co-op
um before you stump go to the next bill
yep 13.99 what happens if the the
building which is in the
withdrawing District
is not owned by the co-op District
but owned by the withdrawing District
it's not that's not a it's not a
possibility that exists
are you talking about Woodsville April
no I'm from Woodsville Haverhill and I'm
not so fine with their Co-op so we have
another District in the state where they
own the building one of the buildings
which is an elementary building
they own it clear the village District
owns it
the statue doesn't address that if so it
might be really simple if the
withdrawing School District owns the
building and that's actually clear and
there's no dispute about it and by the
way oh title and ownership is one of
those really sometimes difficult things
to prove there's no question on this uh
let you know it's town is Bridgewater
okay and they have title ownership no
debt on their building so so the answer
is what why does that why do they have
to pay anything back to the co-op if
they own the property other than the
cost of Capital Improvements maybe that
the co-op made to other buildings no to
the to that building they are building
to their building yes yeah there's got
to be some reimbursement to the co-op
for the improvements that the co-op paid
but in in co-ops made no maintenance has
been paid by Bridgewater that doesn't
seem that confusing to me from just a
logical standpoint and the statute
doesn't address that currently
the bridge their Co-op they go to
Newfound for beyond the Elementary
grades
Chris so 195 28 addresses the the
disposition of property owned by the
co-op not owned by other entities so
that it's not really that's a completely
separate issue and Bridgewater can hire
their own lawyer and their lawyer can
tell them what what happens if that
buildings leased to the co-op for a
dollar a year
that's subject to the terms of the lease
agreement again that's occurring not not
part of 195.28 so that's a separate
contractual arrangement I don't want to
weigh in on the contract between
Bridgewater and you know a school
district but that's a that's one of
those one-year 99-year leases for a
dollar
um it's a it's still a a property
interest that
um the co-op has in the use of the
building so they have to figure out how
to deal with terminating that lease but
that's between those entities
every five years yeah so that's not part
of 195.28
um
the other part of one of 1399 which is
very one-sided and and it's just going
to frustrate efforts for withdrawal is
it says that the withdrawing District
takes its school buildings with them but
must pay back to the other members
um the each member's proportional share
and the net Equity of the co-op
buildings
um so current law states that the
withdrawing District must pay the co-op
back for the actual cost of Capital
Improvements we've already talked about
that
um
can you explain that again because it
says in the co-op buildings
so if there are schools if if the
withdrawing Town leaves and there are
other schools in the co-op the um it
says that the withdrawing District gets
paid for its proportional share and the
value of the rest of the buildings okay
so it's leaving it's abandoning the
co-op there's all this property the
withdrawing District under 13.99 would
get paid for its proportional
uh interest in the the buildings that
it's abandoning current law says the
drawing District if you leave you're
forfeiting your equity in all the
buildings that are left in the co-op you
keep your own you pay your for your own
building but you forfeit your equity in
the other in the other buildings it's
meant to be a little bit difficult to
withdraw this system kind of flips it
around and says well you get paid back
for whatever Equity you have in the
remaining buildings and and the reason
that's unfair is that the the
pre-existing districts in the co-op
I get stunk twice because they have to
cut a check
to the pre-existing District that just
withdrew right and they have to continue
paying for the operating costs of those
districts even after that one of their
members leads and the debt and the debt
the debt these guys are the the
withdrawing district will still have
some indebtedness obligation yeah but
this is assuming there's no debt okay so
the co-op has to cut a check and they
have to continue operating the building
with one of its members gone that's just
gonna make the the co-ops never going to
vote in support of that kind of
withdrawal plan because it it Saddles
them twice with with the money they're
going to cut a huge check and they they
have to keep operating with that member
gone so that provision I think
doesn't work
um and there probably is a better
provision but that's really that's part
three of 13.99
um
part five of 13 uh 1399 addresses the
Assumption of indebtedness
um it it it it it says upon payments um
The Cooperative District shall transfer
and convey title to any building the the
pre-existing District remember that the
the district that withdrew shall assume
any remaining indebtedness for such
School building land or facilities it's
really easy to say that and be like oh
that's nice and clean
the problem is that
um if if if they withdraw with their
building but the bond was issued by the
Cooperative it's not just a matter of
saying all right now we have the Bond as
the town of of of Acme no we you can't
just transfer bonds back and forth that
actually undercuts the in the entire
Bond and you know we I have Bond counsel
in in my firm and we've we've spoken to
them about this but simply
um stating that doesn't address the
consequences of how you transfer it Bond
debt between municipalities
um the risk here is huge because if if
you do it improperly then the bond loses
its tax-exempt status and all of a
sudden the municipality
assumes the indebtedness but also the
bond is no longer tax exempt so that
municipality has to pay taxes that they
haven't paid
that's a I'm not doing a sort of Doom
and Gloom thing I'm just saying you peek
under the bond stuff and you look at the
Arbitrage rules for bonds it's a it's a
very complicated area of the law there's
not a lot of people in the state who do
it and I just would say be very cautious
about dealing with transferring
debt between one municipality which
issued the bond to another municipality
which didn't exist when the bond was
issued it's not that simple and I'm
going to leave it there because
I'm not a bond attorney I don't even
pretend to be one and I have a couple of
we have we have a municipal Finance
um group in our office and I'll I'll
refer to them when I get a call
um
I think
um I know Barrett said this and you're
already talking about this I think a
study Commission of co-ops is like so
long overdue right it's been since 19
the 1990s and
um we we are a different state we have a
different view on school choice in New
Hampshire uh things cost a lot more
money than they cost back back in the
90s and certainly back in the 60s
um we need a commission we need people
on the commission from different parts
of the state and also different uh areas
of expertise that can advise the
commission on these complex issues I
think that's where I at least 13.99
which has has some POS has some
potential
um
and I I I'm not even going to really
address 1366 that's really just a
political a political thing in my view
in 13 in 1679 is a non-starter but with
respect to 1399 and some of the
remaining issues that co-ops are
encountering a commission is
I think a really good idea I'd be happy
to attend I'd happy to sit be sit on it
I was on the 2017 commission and um
offer my assistance just because I find
this to be really interesting work
primarily and also
um I think the state needs to figure
some of these issues out and I'm gonna
I'll stay for questions but thank you
thank you very much informative uh
questions
it has representative Cornell Thank you
thank you for taking my question you
said on the last commission some of the
things didn't come out right because
there wasn't the knowledge that should
have been there so if we did recommend
another commission like what kind of
background or people should be on that
commission I think someone from the the
dra who can advise with respect to
appraisals
um someone familiar with you know real
estate appraisals potentially
um
you know folks in the community who who
want to put the legwork into figuring
out how to how to um
uh
how to deal with the debt and the bond
issue
um I think those are those are big
concerns
um
you know I think we and I think the idea
that that that uh Barrett raised was a
good idea that we want to hear
we want to hear from the community
members to figure out what the issues
are because what happens is
you know
one person from this Cooperative who
lives in this town has this perspective
on co-ops
this person from this town has a totally
different perspective on co-ops there
are some co-ops that are just high
schools there are some that are Middle
School through high school there are
some that are K through 12.
um and so everyone really does have a
different experience and so last time we
spent almost all of our time just trying
to understand the nature of the Beast
and then all the work about how to fix
it we tried to kind of do really quickly
and it really resulted in a couple of
bills but one Amendment came out of the
commission that we thought was going to
really work and that ended up resulting
in the change to 195 18 but I think it's
going to take longer it's going to take
more work to really understand for all
the people to understand the nature of
the co-ops
Jim I see on the that commission I have
that membership in front of me right now
that occurred on the Grine year there
was a representation from the Department
of Revenue Administration did they bring
that type of expertise in or do you need
somebody more specifically you know
Stephen Hamilton was present he did it
he was very kind with his time he did a
quick overview of of some of the issues
but it wasn't a it wasn't really digging
in like someone who could really just
dig in and help out and come up with
static Solutions in language I mean he
he was helpful but I'm not sure I'm not
sure he really knew what the dra's role
was
um
and so he provided helpful uh overview
um I know there was a representative
from the doe who's who's here today and
and there was help from that end too but
I just I I it has to be at the outset
there has to be an intention to kind of
fix some of these problems identify what
they are fix them but first understand
what the nature is of all these co-ops
in the state
thank you yes representative Cornell
every Co-op is different and has
different contracts or agreements would
a commission even be able to come up
with a solution for all of them of how
to do things when they're all different
or should it just be local control and
the people getting together from those
co-ops and making decisions for
themselves right rather than us telling
them what to do I think um there's a
framework right now and the framework
allows for local control amendment of um
of Articles of agreement but there are
some Provisions that really tie off
people's hands and some of those
Provisions for example the disposition
of property language do tie the hands of
the study of the of the withdrawing with
potentially withdrawing towns they do
tie the hands of the Cooperative that
would remain in place so we should be
looking at how with a lighter touch can
we modify some of those restrictions
without really kind of taking the whole
thing apart and starting all over again
I don't think we need to do that that
yes representative Ford
thank you Mr chair and thank you sir for
taking our questions
to what extent does geography play
a factor in this and such as two
elementary schools owned by a co-op
one's in one town one's in the other but
one's a new building and the other one's
an old building and you start trying to
decide who gets what when you divide all
this
yeah I mean geography and and
socio-economic demographics I think play
a huge part and what ends up happening
in my experience is
cooperatives
um
and not everyone but some people in the
community have a different idea than
other people in the community about
what's fair and what's right and so for
instance
um sometimes you look at the cost the
operating costs of the district in
apportionment formulas and you'll heal
hear members of the community saying
well my per pupil cost in my town is
twenty eight thousand dollars and the
per pupil cost in that other town is
only you know eighteen thousand dollars
and that has to do with the equalized
valuation and if the property with more
equalized valuation they're going to
have a higher per pupil cost because
they have higher property values and
more ability to pay that high per pupil
cost but they'll think that's unfair
because they're looking at the the cost
for per student whereas some people will
say well that's fair because you have
you have the ability to raise that money
in your community and we're doing this
together and we agreed we're going to do
this together so it really comes down to
how people think about philosophically
what's fair
what's more important my town
or the collective Cooperative as a whole
that's I think more the most important
issue whether you're in Pittsfield or
Hollis or you know Keen Monadnock or you
know want to come it it's it's always
the same conversation I go to 20 30
school district meetings every year and
it's this it's the same conversations
um and people are very smart all across
the state and they're very tied in with
these issues and it's always a very
similar conversation
thank you that's so
it's a heavy heavy topic uh the prior
chair Ways and Means or you know now
retired was very concerned about what we
were doing last year because he came
from one of those towns just mentioned
that you know was had the dollars and
and well I won't go any further than
that but it's it's really it can this
whole conversation can end up like a
donor Town versus non-donor Town type
discussion it is a it is a miniature
version of that I mean the co-ops like
Barrett said they were they were a
marriage between you know not rich and
poor I don't want to but but the the
towns that didn't have a lot of property
value were put with the towns that did
because I mean and so it is literally a
miniature version of New Hampshire
well thank you very much uh you're
informative as usual thank you I are
there any folks from specific co-ops
that have issues that would like to
discuss those or present those issues to
us
everybody's copacetic
good is there anybody else would you
like will to you know present you know
information to the study committee at
this time
foreign
yes representative Tanner can we hear
from the Department of Education yes I
was going to do that after we you know
okay
um uh
good morning Miss Fenton
yes I think there was another
superintendent
okay he's playing your cards well
um diary
in the morning
so as you all know uh the only thing
that makes
having one attorney is having two
attorneys so I'm happy to introduce Liz
Brown she's also with the Department of
Education
um
for the record my name is Diana Fenton
I'm an attorney with the Department of
Education it's always nice to see
everyone I'm happy to answer any
questions and I always love when
representative Tanner has a question for
me because I know it's going to be a
good one
um so
I like Barrett uh was not around in the
60s hard to believe
um
I can tell you during my tenure with the
Department of Education that we have
received calls from districts asking
questions about the statute similar to
what Barrett testified to we do not
um represent any particular district and
so I I guide them the best I can through
the law
walk them through that process we always
encourage the districts to speak to
their local Council
and and have that person assist them
with that process we really can't do a a
very deep dive on it it is for that
District to reach out to their Council
but what we largely do is kind of assist
them with the paperwork and getting it
ready to go in front of the State Board
and so that's
um where I myself have have assisted
many districts and just making sure that
the formalities and the paperwork are
appropriate for the State Board I can't
recall the last time that we had
um a withdrawal come before the state
board but I can tell you that
um when when they have come before the
State Board one of the areas of concern
that I would encourage this committee to
look at regardless of which legislative
path you take on the bills before you
is to think about what role the State
Board of Education uh plays in this
process and what I mean by that is all
this paperwork comes in front of the
state board and the state board has
historically
kind of said in in fewer words perhaps
well what do we what do we do with this
what is our analysis how deep can we
dive on this and I know sometimes the
State Board in the past has felt like it
is simply a an administrative rubber
stamp that the work has been done and
now they just have to approve it and
send it along other times the board
which as you all know changes in terms
of its makeup other times the board has
pushed back and asked some questions
what's going to happen with this piece
of property where are the students going
to go
um and so depending on the formation of
the board you're going to get very
different questions asked but that has
been kind of an area that the board has
struggled with perhaps I'm sure and
again I'm not here to speak on behalf of
the board of education but I'm sure
clarity as to what that role should be
and is would be appreciated
um along your lines to further answer
your question representative Tanner we
have received calls from constituents
who are upset about their about their
Cooperative
um wanting to withdraw from it
explaining that it's it's an unfair
process
um it's a marriage that cannot end in
some parents that cannot end I have uh
in the past I have been sent to school
board meetings of various cooperatives I
went to Jeffrey wrench
um for a school board meeting where
their Cooperative was having some issues
I've been to Orford in Vermont New
Hampshire border I'm trying to address
some of these issues I think the role
the department plays is somewhat limited
and it is always just coming back to to
the law in what is allowed under the law
we are not there to advise we're not
there to guide so a lot of the time I
spend listening to the concerns and
trying to to direct the best I can so I
I have made those trips myself
um to various times but I I do so with
another attorney from a firm such as Jim
O'Shaughnessy or other firms that
represent districts in that capacity and
really defer to that individual
um
so sometimes I'm not sure how helpful my
role is but yes I have been to the
meetings
um there was a question that was asked
earlier about and I just want to make
sure that I address the point um and
I'll give you a little background of who
I am and how I ended up here because I I
think I was involved in that last
withdrawal study and it's just sort of
by uh so you are the Elizabethan
I believe I was roped in by two
attorneys that are behind me one to my
right and one to my left
um so um at the time I believe I may
have been the chair of the Hollis
Brookline Cooperative School District I
was the chair for about three years I
was on the board for almost nine before
um I was hired by the commissioner to be
counseled to the Department of Education
I've only been at the department now
since June
um so I'm still relatively new and so I
fielded far less called I guess from
constituents and school districts than
Diana has in her last several years I
think we met originally when I was
active on the board we met on the steady
commission yeah so um and uh so we've
had these conversations for a while so I
have a pretty good understanding of at
least one Co-op
um and I've been on the study commission
and kind of remember the work and I
think that
um the work that Barrett and Jim
previously described and how that
committee went is would be an accurate
description of how I would describe that
work
um is it was a lot of work tried to be
done in a very short amount of time
after there was a lot of venting because
we learned that the co-ops were all very
very different
um and they all come but one of the
questions I want to make sure that I
address just so you know in my short
tenure
um there was and ironically I was on the
board that had the the re-look at our
articles of agreement so
um back about eight months ago
um the Hollis Brookline Cooperative had
a special meeting to have a vote on
amending the house Cooperative agreement
articles of agreement because it became
apparent to some members of the board
that they were kind of outdated there
was just things that didn't reflect what
we did they didn't reflect the times
they didn't reflect current law so those
were amended by the by the town like a
special meeting of the co-op there was a
vote and then those articles of
agreement just came before the State
Board of Education
um in July and those were reviewed so
there are just there are co-ops that are
actively reviewing them and going
through that full process I don't know
if there's other but that is one that
has I've encountered since I've been
employed by the by the board of uh the
department of the Department of
Education and Advising the board yes
sorry maybe more coffee would be a good
idea this morning but that is one that
has come before us in the last three
months why I've been at the department
just so you are aware of that one thank
you during the time you were doing that
I sat beside in the house he
representative came from Brookline I
heard about Co-op issues every day I was
sitting in session
um I won't mention his name but you
don't need to you know who I'm talking
about okay
um so then the the question I have to
you and and of course you're one of
three that were on the previous
Commission in this room right now four
of us four of you on it the Two of Us in
Barrett and Jim okay and so I've I've
heard just recently from the prior
speaker here that it would be a good
idea to have a commission study to
eliminate some of the confused uh
language within law and help streamline
that
um are you of the same opinion
I actually think that would be a good
idea I think that would be a
comprehensive look
um because each of these statutes impact
other statutes
um for example if we looked at the and I
don't remember the house bill but the
house bill that would basically
eliminate all the Cooperative 16 19 97.
um that would have impact on things like
building Aid
um and so it needs to be a comprehensive
look once you've changed one statute
that deals with co-ops it's going to
change two or three other statutes that
are not in a cooperative
statute you know realm they're going to
change other things so it needs to be a
much more comprehensive look
um and I actually think Vera's
suggestion of having you know allowing
some districts to come in and and talk
and and vent and um because I have had a
district come um before me at this point
um already as well I've been at the um
Department
um really being in that unhappy marriage
because they're a small District that
can't effectuate the change
um because they can't get enough votes
but I do think there's there's a lot of
different flavors
um of co-ops um and I think that that
might be a really good place to start
and examining these but also allow more
comprehensive and careful look at how a
change in one statute would impact a
number of other non-cooperative related
statutes
yeah I I think we've talked about like a
mission
and I think that's the right way to go
and it's important to note it's a
commission not a legislative committee
yeah
because there's a huge difference
between the voices that are in the room
in the legislative committee vis-a-vis
that of a commission
where you have people from the public
who are engaged in the commission work
where you can't in a legislative
committee
and I think it's important to have those
voices there
because there is vested interest in
there and there's experience that those
of us that are in the legislative part
of it don't have
so I would I would concur
that as we look at this uh Mr chairman
that we continue to focus on on the
commission work and not a legislative
committee work
well that that's why you know when I did
appoint Jim uh Grenier as the chair of
that it was a commission study and we
saw that and I think that what you're
saying is absolutely so that we want the
expertise out there we've muddled around
through this for so long uh we need to
have some of that
we need some accountants on there some
people that can assess things properly
and and and and give us the information
we really need to make a
good statute good law so are there any
further questions for you either uh
attorneys Brown and Fenton
yes representative Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question just as
a follow-up you talked about how your
your actions at the State Department of
Education seem to be reactive to the
issues that are coming to you
um and as I pointed out
in my ancient you know dinosaur years
um that at in the 60s when for example
the Curious Arch District formulated
there were a lot of incentives in the
Department of Education was really
um supporting co-ops in many many ways
as uh
talking to the uh you know they had
meetings and conferences with the
teachers that were going into that Co-op
how how to work with the different
schools coming together there was
building Aid that sort of thing
um
today
what's happening at the Department of
Education if anything to support the
co-ops
or to Simply react to the questions of
breaking up co-ops
I don't think there are any actions that
you have described which occurred when
they were being formed nor would it seem
appropriate for the Department to
undertake that work since they have been
formed I think that was a reaction of
the of that particular time so I think
that the
support that the department offers is
the support that we that we offer to all
school districts and it's just kind of a
holistic approach but there's nothing
particular to cooperatives such as you
have described
um that is being undertaken to the best
of my knowledge
are there yes representative
we had a bit of a list
started as to who should be on this
commission do you have any to add to it
well I would recommend Jim O'Shaughnessy
uh I was fascinated by his testimony
as you know the department
um
you know we
we provide information and so it's a
rare occasion when I would say to you
certainly this person certainly that
person but
um
there are a lot of people out here
clearly that I have a lot of really
valuable information about cooperatives
and that's the information that needs to
be presented to this committee and and I
would encourage you
um to reach out to those resources
namely when attorney O'Shaughnessy
mentioned that attorney at his firm that
works with bonds
um that's critical information to bring
forward to this committee and I can tell
you that is a very specialized area
um certainly Falls far outside of my
purview and that's the kind of detailed
information that this committee would
would need and those resources and those
people are out there my experience from
the last study Commission in 2017
um it was that it felt very rushed
it felt very rushed and I think the
subtext of all the testimony today is
that this is an area that needs a very
thoughtful approach
and to address uh representative
Cornell's um concerning questions I
think that formula or that guidance or
that that that blueprint as I like to
call it can be achieved I think that
right balance can be struck but it's
going to take some time and what we've
seen over the legislative sessions every
session there's a bill or two that deals
with cooperatives and you know that it's
a problem this legislative committee
knows it is an issue and what it needs
is a very thoughtful approach and that
sometimes just takes time
and I would encourage this committee to
to do that it is a worthwhile endeavor
the previous commission the the charge
and study purpose was a singular
sentence here with a couple
bullets underneath it said the
commission shall study issues relating
to the withdrawal of pre-existing
districts from their Cooperative School
District including
if we go with a commission would you
recommend that there be a broader the
study the issues relating to Cooperative
school districts period
I think that based upon the comments
we've heard today I think that would be
more comprehensive although I think that
might be too large I mean maybe we need
to consider is it
um what all issues we want you know it's
withdrawal disillusion which are
different
um but it certainly needs to include
both of those
um and maybe include you know finance
and some other issues that could be
apportionment of board seats I don't
know if you want to go as broad as just
simply the study of cooperatives
um I think that might become
overwhelming and you might have a
five-year study commission rather than a
two-year
um so there's got to be a balance
between what I think was very very
narrow
um in that prior study because you get
together with Jim and Barrett and others
that are involved with this and try to
drop a list of bullets that we might
want to consider as a body here sure
yeah yes Dave thanks Rick
um and um you know I think also the the
components that go into articles of
agreement probably need to be more more
completely laid out and then with and I
and I liked um
um Jim o'shaughnessy's uh language with
a little bit of a light touch to the to
the definition and and um and you know
characteristics of uh for each of those
points going back to going back a
million years to my Commerce phase we
did some similar things in condo law uh
where condo and I you know two very
different things here but condo
agreements were all over the place and
um and uh chair hunt
um really did you know with a with I
think a fairly light touch provides
provide I had a light touch I had a
light well you know John you know and
and and and it does fall into the you
know contracts uh position but um but
but to but to put some sort of framework
and some blueprint as as Patty calls it
to um you know to these things you know
I think we've got a we've got a um
um you know a record of being able to do
things like this so I I think what
you're all suggesting is terrific and I
think at this point you know the 2017
study commission to the rest of my
recollection there's been an enormous
focus on the history of cooperatives
kind of the question of how did we get
here and I think those those questions
have been answered I think there's been
a lot of discussion about that and I
think it's been most appreciative
um and appreciated rather
to understand the how did we get here
and now I think as as a legislative
committee as a group of citizens we're
ready for the next logical step which is
where do we go from here and so I think
that's where the study committee can
kind of pivot a little bit in its work
to the broader understanding of so now
what how do we how do we work with what
we have we understand how it got formed
and now we need to to Pivot a little bit
in our analysis
we've heard that some districts may not
have articles of agreement if they are
formed Freer prior to should they all
have articles of agreement
yeah maybe if so so well I think well
that's a question maybe we have to ask
and that's that's our decision here but
um I representative Ladd I think we all
need to take a moment to recognize you
asked a question that um stumped two
lawyers not just one so that's very good
again Ask two lawyers I'll get three
answers exactly
it depends
um
so I I but that is that is one of the
considerations is there has to be a
recognition that there are properties
formed before the statute was created
and how will they be affected by it
um and I know I worked with Senator
Reagan on creating a a bill from the
2017 commission that was
recognized that difference and so I
think we put in a time frame on that
um moving forward so these are all
things considerations for the study
commission to think about
okay thank you very much uh further
questions for our attorneys here well I
I just I think we had another answer I
actually had another question answer to
her question I think that you want to
make sure you've got some Educators at
the table
um because in many of the discussions
that um I've heard
um maybe in my
non-legal capacity
um it's become a math question
um whether we should continue in a co-op
versus an education question it is a
comprehensive question and we always
have to keep it in the context of it is
a school and we're trying to educate
kids so we definitely want to make sure
that we're including Educators in that
conversation and what types of courses
rigor and curriculum can we offer in a
in a co-op versus individual districts
and that at least be part of the factors
that are considered in that conversation
so we don't get too wrapped up in dra
good formulas and you know property
values that we also remember this is an
education bill
so so Rick if I may in summary then
are we asking the attorneys present here
and I would also add perhaps a
superintendent or two
to get together and come back to this
group
with some recommendations on what that
Commission
task might be as well as the composition
a person of individual types to be on
that commission is that what is that
what we're asking we'll take all the
input from them and we can get but
however when it comes down to the basic
policies like you know if policy people
on there we'll make those decisions I
understand that but uh I think yes we
are asking them you know what what are
some of the charges the duties that this
group needs to cover if it's too broad
we probably won't get anywhere but if
it's going to nail down what we've
discussed here today
um I'd welcome their their input on
membership and what those charges should
be and I think that's the what that's
the first step to trying to tackle this
thing in a way that perhaps we haven't
tackled it in the in the past and we we
would be happy to do that we'll see by
that I know the legislature is getting
tired of having so many committees and
commissions so I can't even identify the
number that I'm on and it's you know you
wonder are we really achieving anything
I think we can achieve something with
this if it's done properly the because
there is and we hear that maybe
one-third of our folks out there in
co-ops may have issues one way or
another
well that's that's a number which I
think's high and you know and we we got
to resolve that and that's if we're
going to do something this might be the
way to do it
further questions
I'm not missing it thank you very much
thank you is there anybody else today
superintendents from the education
policy side anything like that uh
anything to present or just make us
aware of
foreign
ERS I'm the superintendent of conval
um and I just want to pay back on
something attorney Brown said and that
is that this sounds and it's beginning
to feel like it's a math problem but the
truth is is that the Cooperative school
districts
work under Articles of agreement most of
them
um our articles agreement and combound
have to be reviewed every three years
our articles of agreement in kanbal
include a representative Committee of
all the Selectmen of the towns
so there are articles of agreement
that represent what I think you might be
looking for
but more important than that is any
commission or any study that the
legislature decides to do should also
include
the softer side if you will which I know
for some of you is very hard to talk
about and that is that at the end of the
day
each
Co-op also has an identity
in 55 the 55 years of the conval
Co-op has been together that people in
our towns in the nine towns that we
serve identify themselves as belonging
to the conval
School District
that happens because many a particularly
larger co-ops become the state in
miniature
they become miniature municipalities
and people identify as from that area
where are you from I'm from the conval
school district
not all co-ops I just I think this was
misspoken not all co-ops have multiple
districts some co-ops are simply one
District like the Kentucky Valley School
District
um so I was a little confused I think I
don't know if someone misspoke they were
built on cost sharing they're built on
providing the best education to students
the best resources to students and
they're built on local control
and that's important to those miniature
states that they are allowed to control
their destinies
so as you're considering a commission
you should also remember that
you are entering into an area where many
of these towns
have had 55 years of local control over
their Cooperative School District
and many of them have agreements a
browned dissolution
for instance in our Cooperative District
we have one town that should the
building no longer be used for
educational purposes it gets returned to
the town
we have another agreement with a
different town
they own the property but we own the
building sounds like a condo doesn't it
so please be aware as you begin to look
and and pull back the layers of the
onion
that there are multiple types of
agreements there are multiple types of
co-ops
and while every Co-op is a little
different of course they have
similarities many of our co-ops if you
look carefully about where they are
have been designed because of their
rural locations
so if you do create a commission I would
highly encourage you to consider having
somebody on there that understands rural
communities that understands is an
expert in rural education because it is
different than Urban education and
understands rural economics
because they're rural poor are different
than the urban poor and the Suburban
poor finally I want to just follow
through on a narrative that has
continued through each of these
um
test of testimonies and that's the the
idea that a co-op is a marriage
certainly there are all types of
marriages and when you're hanging out
with your friends you may complain about
your marriage
that doesn't mean you don't want to be
in it
it doesn't mean that and at the base of
it there are problems
although I'd like to see a marriage that
doesn't have them
and it's certainly I don't think anyone
in the room
would say gosh marriage has its problems
let's dissolve the institution
all right thank you my colleague is uh
very bold and wanting to speak first I
hesitate to try and follow that up so
thank you secondly I also stand between
you and I believe lunch so books being a
precarious position to begin uh my name
is David Ryan I'm superintendent in
sau16 representing six towns there's a
difference between an SAU as you know
and a Cooperative School District
the Exeter region Cooperative School
District was formed in 1996
also that the six towns could send their
students coming from their local
elementary schools
to high achieving High achieving middle
school and a high achieving High School
they've been working under an area
agreement which as you know has limited
governing ability for the legislative
body of each of those towns submitting
students to those schools budgets are
typically set by the local board
tuitions are set and those tuitions are
then paid having worked also in SAU 53
we experienced that uh one year
particularly
where our Pembroke voters and our
Allentown Epsom and Chichester voters
along with the voters of Deerfield
differed on what the costs were going to
be for tuition at Pembroke Academy
we don't experience that now as a
Cooperative School District
so the Middle School The Cooperative
Middle School was built in 1998 and then
the high school followed with 2004.
Cooperative Middle School is in the town
of Stratham
the high school is in the town of extra
so the issue of dissolution becomes even
more problematic with the transfer of a
building should there be a dissolution
of two Cooperative buildings built in
the spirit of sharing costs and
achieving higher levels of rigor for all
students
so that's a question in my mind and I'm
going to make my attempt to stay in my
Lane as representing just SAU 16 but I
share my colleagues concern for those
north of this city
and the representation that they have or
have not and the uh the obstacles that
they face in the North country
uh and try and educate students at high
levels
I'm fortunate right now to be working on
the task force for minimum academic
standards and in that task force we've
been working through a framework of
equity to ensure that all students are
achieving at high levels and that we
have policy that surrounds
those outcomes for all kids leaving it
to local school districts to make the
decision and choices
on how students achieve those high
levels
so local control remains strong but as a
state trying to enact policy
that make sure that every single student
has the same opportunities
for high level outcomes some may not get
there not all will get there but they'll
all have the same opportunity and
expectations
we believe our Cooperative School
District does the same thing in the
Seacoast region
in the town of Brentwood we have a K-5
school as we do in four of our other
Five Towns the town of Exeter we have
two elementary schools a k to two and a
three to five
all knowing that they're going to be
moving on together to Cooperative Middle
School for those who choose to move on
to Cooperative Middle School in the
event that we were to eliminate either
the Cooperative Middle School and or
Exeter High School each of those
districts would still then be able they
required to educate their students at
the secondary level
and as the superintendent who provides
the services under the SAU for those six
communities we would be forced to
negotiate tuition agreements
for all secondary services
some of the issues and this goes back to
representative myler's question thank
you with regard to cost
is we work through a transportation
budget that requires us to have a double
run of our buses in order to adequately
afford this expansive square footage or
square mileage of our communities to get
kids to school on time
in the event that we're not able to
provide that because the dissolution of
the Cooperative takes place
we're now required to negotiate
individual Transportation contracts with
each of our six communities
and keep in mind it would not all be
going to the same destination
there's Epping High School there's
Sanborn there would certainly still be
Exeter
there could be Dover there could be
whatever the tuition agreements that
these communities want to come up with
as a resident of Hooksett
in SAU 15 my own children have attended
Manchester High School so my last one
will attend and graduate from Central
High School this year
not all students in the town of Hooksett
are going to Manchester as you know they
had a tuition agreement as well we had
no say in the budget
we had no say in representation on the
boards and so the decisions that were
being made in the city of Manchester
were those decisions that were passed on
to the sending towns Bedford spoke with
their feet
so in in in the Seacoast region where we
have a strong Cooperative School
District that was built specifically to
provide all of our students in our six
towns with a high level academic
experience and be able to offer all of
the programming that we believe they
need to be successful
and I'm talking about advanced placement
course
uh other dual enrollment courses working
with area colleges opportunities for the
music and arts for athletics we have to
pool our resources and that's what they
decided to do back prior to 1996 when
they worked to form a Cooperative school
district there are a couple of points
that I wanted to make my idea of uh or
my thoughts about a commission are are
quite positive and in that we were
um I can't recall if it was
representative Miler or luna or lad that
suggested a couple of superintendents be
a part of that commission I would be
more than willing to volunteer to be a
part of that group
one of the things that I think we would
need to address however are all
governing structures because I'm not
certain that all of the members of our
legislative body
understand the difference between a
Cooperative School District
an area agreement or other forms of
governance because what happens with
voters is when they're told their vote
no longer counts I think they get fairly
upset and should people wish to secede
from a Cooperative school district and
recognize that they no longer have
representation on the school board
of a school to which they're sending
their children I'm not certain that they
would be very happy with that I think
people don't understand
so a commission I think has a duty to
educate
its voters as well so people can
understand what it is that they would be
ultimately voting for
the loss of control the loss of the seat
on the board the development of a budget
the ability to vote for a budget that
weighs heavy on me for the folks that I
represent the families I represent not
just the families whose children attend
our schools but for the close to 80
percent of the families who live in our
six towns who don't have children in our
schools
their tax dollars all fund our schools
and if they were then to be informed
that their tax dollars were going
somewhere that they didn't have a say in
that's a large body of people that I
don't want to have to face
the last thing I would like to ask is
that uh the the Genesis of these these
bills particularly those to dissolve um
The Cooperative my question to the
committee one thing I'd ask that you
remember is this is a is this a question
of constitutionality
are there things inherently wrong in the
law regarding Cooperative school
districts
or is this a question of
wanting to provide other choices and
opportunities for people in towns to do
what they want to do with regard to
education
in either case
there are going to be consequences and
ramifications for both
what I'd like to leave with you is an
sau16 our Cooperative School District
operates very well
and as my colleagues have shared before
there are folks including members of
this committee who might have some
differences of opinion on how it should
work but we do have a democratic process
that we follow every year to determine
whether or not it's going the best that
it can and we always do that with a
focus on what's best for our kids
I think thank you very much I'd be happy
to answer any questions any questions
for these superintendents
not seeing thank you very much both of
you thank you
so with that we are you know at an hour
where we're I think we are ready to
adjourn this meeting however we need to
set a meeting one more meeting here in
which we will develop a recommendation
to make to the whole and hopefully we
will have that some of that feedback
back from folks here as to if we go the
route of a commission then we'd have
that and I asked everybody on the
committee here it'd be also thinking
about you know you know charges that
might be given to a commission study
and I want to thank everybody who took
the time to come away from your busy
schedules today for this this is a topic
which is
pretty pretty heady and and speak to the
you know the the the need uh for for
this in school building Aid we have a
condition called consolidation uh to to
ensure that we're not splitting up in in
having buildings we try to consolidate
students into one facility and that will
in the application process that will
give you additional dollars uh the
efficiency of the dollar efficiency in
in of the educational practices as well
uh putting People Under One Roof in in
from multiple locations so uh we
understand and uh I think that the
recommendation this group comes up what
is going to be a good one and hopefully
lead to some resolve on this this issue
has plagued us myself for the last 14
years and I know for many many others
over 50 years and so
um thank you any further comments from
the group here today
if not it's time for lunch isn't it
next meeting
um
yeah get your get your calendars out
let's look
uh let me go get my calendar
foreign
so in October
how much is 12.
uh
Columbus Day is the 10th
we have I have one two three the
previous week
we have 1680 on the third
teacher shortage on the fourth the
pipeline
and meals and all that on the 6th
so looking at the week of the 10th
and
pardon me it all works for you right now
it works for me and it's best to get
this plugged in so
by tomorrow may not work
so so what what's good for the community
any day is good for me on there so
the Wednesday of 12th
3 30. how about in the morning yes that
we so yeah 9 30 be good
yeah
so 9 30 on October 12th this this uh
interim study committee will meet and
we'll we'll come up with some kind of
resolution uh as far where we're going
with the bill
12th at 9 30.
that's good with everybody
thank you that was easy thank you very
much and everybody have a good afternoon
bill